roughly 9% of the rubbish we believe
could be recycled instead so let's take
a closer look at how to use the
recycling bin
everything you put into the bin should
be clean and loose not in a bag and lids
and tops from bottles and jars should be
removed if they're plastic they should
go in the rubbish any scrap metal can be
recycled at Southbrook resource recovery
Park other items that can't be accepted
include broken glass milk or juice
cartons also known as tetrapack
polystyrene and soft plastics soft
plastics include anything you can easily
scrunch up into your hand this includes
bubble wrap food wrap chip packets and
plastic bags nappies should go on the
rubbish and food sword cardboard like
pizza boxes or napkins should go into
your organics bin for composting so what
should go into your recycling glass
bottles and jars bottles and containers
made from plastic type 1 through 7
tonnes cans and aerosols and loose clean
flat cardboard and paper to learn more
or to sign up for collection reminders
visit 1 a kediri govt tnz forward slash
rethink rubbish